thomas bon soir alors qu'elle est un
l'atmosphère autour de cette soirée
thomas et bien côté olivier la soirée
touche à sa fin puisque les convives
sont en train de quitter le grand palais
ils ont été reçus notamment donc par le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand qui
a prononcé un discours notamment pour
rendre hommage au personnel hospitalier
mais aussi aux personnes qui ont perdu
un proche pendant cette pandémie du coc
vide 19 n'ayant pas pu entrer au sein de
ce grand palais on a interrogé les
participants à cette soirée pour qu'il
nous donne quelques détails sur ce qu'il
s'est passé c'est au micro cynthia
lauvergeon ok il n'a pu se faire
normalement tout le monde pourquoi
masquer distanciation sociale voilà
quand il est lu un discours de monsieur
le ministre et puis voilà un petit pot
de l'amitié
c'était très il a remercié tous les
soignants
moi j'ai trouvé un raid entre humains
voilà très humain vis-à-vis du personnel
soignant des secondes lignes aussi très
reconnaissance un très beau discours je
pense que tout le personnel soignant est
en attente qu'on attend de voir ce que
ça va donner dans les mois qui viennent
que c'était lent qui a été magnifique
vis-à-vis des soignants ne retombe pas
et on n'attend que ça je suis venu parce
que ben justement j'ai perdu ma temps de
cette maladie qui était soignante dans
une maison de retraite
déjà quand on m'a appelé je n'ai pas cru
et j'ai fait c'était une blague
pour ce cet événement je trouve que
c'est bien de rendre hommage aussi aux
personnes qui malheureusement perdu la
vie parce que va malheureusement je
pense que les français ne se rendent pas
forcément compte ça m'a fait plaisir que
l'on reconnaisse aussi que les soignants
qui y ont perdu la vie
ils ont une petite reconnaissance quand
même une réception d'ordre symbolique
qui va se poursuivre pour un certain
nombre de participants demain puisque
qu'ils assisteront aux célébrations pour
la fête nationale ici dans la capitale
une célébration qui intervient aussi
dans un contexte un peu particulier
puisque les accords du ségur de la santé
ont été signés ce lundi et certains
participants nous expliquait être
content d'être reçue ainsi par le
ministre de la santé dans ce lieu
emblématique qu'elle
emballé mais que effectivement il
fallait qu'on laissait sur les actes
concrets attendent des actes concrets de
la part du gouvernement le ségur en fait
partie même si on sait que cela ne
convainc pas tout le monde et puis un
mot plus anecdotique pour vous dire que
les tenues de soirée était de mise ce
soir ici au grand palais mais un
accessoire était sur tous les visages
c'est évidemment le masque puisque selon
le ministre de la santé lui-même les
distances et les mesures sanitaires
devaient absolument être respectée ce
soir merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes
ces précisions thomas bonnin en direct
devant le grand palais à paris